my horse always does the thing where
she'll like
shake her head oh my god now i'm
pretending to be a horse um
when i think of an equestrian i think of
someone that's like dedicated a lot of
their life
to riding horses when i hear the term
horse girl i just think of the girl who
kind of like
feels understood by horses kindergarten
through like fifth grade i was
definitely like that one kid in class
any like writing reading project in
school like it was all about horses
i was definitely a worst girl i would
like sleep over at the barn
i never considered myself a horse girl
but if i ever tell
my friends that i do horseback riding
they will call me a horse girl
me when i was younger honestly
the music makes it so good she kept her
neck tucked
she was like actually emulating how
horses move
the jumps that she was jumping in the
video were probably like
a 9 out of 10 difficulty they were
massive
as a little bit creepy as that looks i
used to
go in the horse ring and jump over jumps
but i didn't do it on all fours
i could never do it when i was on my
hands and my legs so maybe she's like a
level above me in horse girliness
i remember it being like really
difficult because i
was never very athletic every person
who's obsessed with horses when they
were younger did
like human jumping at some point you
ever look at someone and wonder what is
going on
inside their head
my horse does that all the time and i
think it's really funny so
silly honestly it just makes me
nostalgic to hang out with horses again
you do develop a bond with the horses
understanding your horse is
really important it's nice to ride one
that you've never ridden before but
with the horses that i've ridden for a
couple years i feel like it's just
different because when i go into the
show ring i
feel like i know them well and i know
how it's going to go there has to be
trust they would be there if i had a bad
day i know there's something people hear
a lot but they're honestly like your
best friend when your teacher yells at
you for biting the other kids in class
[ __ ] you mrs smith okay
oh my gosh i feel like that's more on
the vibe of course girl than equestrian
i actually didn't tell anybody at my
school that i did horseback riding
until probably this past year
and the only reason why i started like
being more open about it
was because i felt like i didn't care
about people making fun of me
maybe not like that like erratic but you
definitely
see that type of behavior sometimes i
definitely knew people that
would scare people that were not
indoctrinated into the horse culture
things that equestrian savers what they
actually mean part two so someone will
ask you
hey you want me to hold your horse for
you while you go grab that and your
response will be like oh no thank you i
got i'll just take him with me but thank
you so much
but what you actually mean is oh my god
no thank you so much like i'm okay but i
just don't want you touching my horse
yeah like maybe keep a six foot distance
if possible
thankfully at my barn i don't have to
worry about anybody
messing up my horse i know that
everybody is really comfortable around
horses
i can completely relate to the feeling
of not wanting someone to hold my horse
a lot of
people that aren't used to holding
horses
can get really intimidated by that yeah
i know this is kind of cheesy to say but
your like negative nervous energy can
rub off on them
it's just not safe horses will jump at
the sound of a plastic bag down the hall
[Music]
my horse always does a thing where
she'll like
shake her head oh my god now i'm
pretending to be a horse um
yeah this one i definitely relate to out
of
the all the ones we've watched so far i
think we need to remember like when
people watch
like upper level riding people
underestimate how much effort is put in
and how much time is committed
not only on the rider's part but also on
the horse's part people work really hard
to get to that level and that
like connectivity with your horse to do
very complex
movements while that is very difficult
and complicated your relationship with
your horse is still
that of you know your friend your pet
good morning breakfast in bed fresh
carrots
i deliberately kept my romantic life and
my like time at the barn separate
i love you too that was funny i enjoyed
that
okay yeah this one's a little
unrelatable yeah like bringing all of
those like
weird things you do or say at the barn
into your relationship makes me like
full body cringe
i think that these like memes and tick
tocks of like horse girls are really
entertaining but i do think that it's
good to be
for people to understand that there's
also equestrians
that put a lot of their life into this
and it means more to them
horseback riding has taught me a lot of
resilience sometimes you will literally
be thrown from a horse
and then you just have to get right back
on and do it over again part of it is
definitely going to have fun
but another part of it is competing and
doing well in kind of
building a future for yourself above all
things i think being in equestrian
really built me up
and built up my confidence
you